gabrielle at center back
over harry maguire you're not mentioning
gabrielle
you're a fraud man wait there hold on
six players right there man for man your
team's not better than that the way
there it's a big shout out you know how
can you not mention gabriel i'm taking
gabrielle you've taken six players yeah
and only one of them gets them
11. what's that i told you this already
we're not doing that we're doing man for
man six out of 11. your team's not
better than us
[Music]
it came kitted out as well
well uh some of us got to support our
teams i mean
now you've got loads of support this is
nice this is nice what's happening good
how are you feel like i'm going on a
date now yeah i know it's all right it's
not
um do you want to cheers before because
it's the only thing we're going to agree
on just to say hello how do you know
well i don't know you're going to say
some outlandish stuff i can just feel it
it's not normally in your character but
i just feel today's a bit different i
don't know we'll see
arsenal will finish above united
this ate with my full chest though i'll
be honest it's not reminded because yeah
even though you're not playing the most
convincing football and you're not
getting the results that everyone
expects for them with the players that
you have in your squad i don't think
anyone should sleep on my united that's
why i'm worried about you because
there's certain players that are
starting to have a little bit of formula
sancho that's coming into it now bruno
fernandez can show up on his day yeah
ronaldo is talking about one in tunnels
like that but on his day that's it yeah
so it's worrying but i have to say
i don't like doing this just do it man
arteta's arteta
annoys me so he's got a lot of he's got
a lot of things about him that annoy me
yeah like the way he collapsed what
like he claps
his cat yeah because now i said you're
gonna go you're gonna you're messing
with me you can say oh yes what you mean
what well if you clap you've got to cut
your hands okay if you clap not everyone
like this yeah but you don't clap with
your hands like a high five like that do
you that's what he does he has yeah i've
seen him do that he's like he's doing it
it's not that deep it is it's annoying
but
i have to give it to him
he's got them buying in
and actually there's a realization as a
united fan i'll be deadly honest with
you you know that kind of like
smug thing of like but they're just
asking them and we're just way better
than him
well
we're not doing a thing yeah we're not
doing anything so i can do that within
the safe walls of here
but you know i mean if i think about it
we're a lot
closer than we might think and the fact
that we're battling out for top four and
i can't even with my chest say you ain't
getting it yeah we definitely are like
if you if you would have told me five
years ago that might not be about the
top four i'll be like what we should
laugh arsenal exactly so quickly return
rebuild our tables turn nine
okay
talking about tables turning if
our game was played tomorrow as both
teams stand now how we're both
performing
do you think you'll be arsenal
draw
so you don't you don't hear me no yeah
no i don't know what no i do i do think
that because no do you know what i do
you know what i do i tell you what i do
if i look at arsenal i wouldn't say
you're like unbelievable you're not
dispatching of teams with ease but
you're just fighting to the end
with us
we're actually playing quite well but
not scoring i think i don't think that's
going to continue to from now to the
holy season so if you when will you
start scoring against you
that was comfortable
and you know what you've got me now
because yeah because i'm not going to
sit here and be like you're not awesome
well i'm scared awesome going to beat us
no you're not going to talk against us
we will we made that mistake at old
trafford earlier this season it's not
going again and you was wondering a lot
exactly and then you just stopped that
so it's even i was coming today for not
letting you in do you think you'll be us
i think arsenal will beat you
i think the the mentality that they have
right now
they don't want to take any one prisoner
they're in this they're in this moment
and they're young they're fearless got
nothing to lose and they're just like we
have to get top four look at our
opponents look how they've been playing
let's not mess it up and then fourth be
a big turnaround you thought you were
are you doing that what i'm just saying
where did you think you thought you'd
finish about what you know what i'm not
gonna lie i thought after you know like
when was in 20th remember it was in 20th
at one point in the season yeah i was
early on i was like you know we might
finish eighth again or ninth i said
ninth
because i was so like mum i had no hope
but now you think you're gonna finish
fourth yeah do you think you need it
okay
man for man
arsenal's strongest eleven is currently
better than manchester united
three
two
one no it can't be before it can't be
yeah
i'm strongly calm down yeah strong we're
battling for full field
actually yeah i'll give you that give
the fact i have to be honest the fact
that you've come to this side of the
table
i can respect that you know why because
on paper your players are better than
our players and this is where to be fair
with the amount we've spent on our squad
to assemble it we spent over
we've got the highest wage bill in the
league i think that the the state of
development and the money that we've
spent our output should be way higher
than what your expectancy should be but
definitely man for man
our squads should be better than yours
with the money we've spent and it is
it's not but in reality
it's not i agree that it is better for
who they are that you've got superstars
in your squad but you cannot say that
they are categorically better than
arsenal than us right now is ben white
is ben white a better defender than
rafael varan in the premier league yes
but on paper no but what he's done at
real madrid
it doesn't matter whether it's on paper
whether it's on the blackboard are we
talking about are we talking about it
doesn't matter we're talking about
raphael for manchester united i'm
talking about and then for arsenal i'm
talking about forget because i'm not
saying that's like me saying real madrid
raphael around versus brighton ben white
no no just the player yeah if there was
a champions league final tomorrow yeah
and you have to choose between ben white
and rafael varan who are you picking
it's a tough one what are you thinking
about from what i've seen recently are
you blowing what are you thinking about
what are you thinking about it's tough
you know
champions league final are you going to
pick a man who's been there and done it
in one champions league four times with
real madrid or you're going to pick them
up players around him raphael he had way
better players around him at real madrid
you can so you're gonna pick white i
can't pick i can't pick because we could
do the whole man for man thing if you
really want
go on so okay
full backs
i don't really want to talk about them
no you have to no because you said we
could go man for man not half a man
yeah so full bats i'm saying i concede
it you'll concede it yeah so maybe on
paper arsenal are a bit i just told you
just i just said two full backs that's
two players no
whole 11. it's a whole team
no is your whole team what's that not
the question it's a man for man
for man i don't know yeah yeah so put
that back
so you're naming all these players
coming at me with ronaldo and all this
but be honest yeah yeah are there any
arsenal players right now currently that
you would want in manchester united
squad yeah
there is thomas party can't have him
we're gone
you can't do that sorry
you can't ask me all right listen i
can't have him i know that but this is
who if i had a free reign to change why
you're over fred or someone of course
okay either fred or mctominy or whatever
mm-hmm tom's partying he said whatever
no i think that's what's better you know
no it's not it's not it's not it's not
it's not um i'll take thomas party
hundred percent
uh i would take sakura okay 100
um and i would
i mean smith rowe wouldn't start but i
take him for squad death really good
player i like him
is there anyone else martinelli
do you like martinelli
considering what's happened recently
yeah i need another player like that so
we'll go with him i'll take him but in
all honesty i've named what about four
players i'll take five players i'll take
take tommy
gabrielle at center back
over harry maguire you're not mentioning
gabrielle
you're a fraud man wait there hold on
six players
man for man your team's not better than
that the way there it's a big shout out
you know how can you not mention captain
hook i'm taking gabrielle you've taken
six players yeah and only one of them
gets
11.
i told you this already
we're not doing that we're doing man for
man six out of 11. your team's not
better than us no i'm not even good at
that and i know that's more
i've just
i just put a bag of them on the bench
they can hold my bench i've just let go
of martial i've just let go of donny van
der beek lingard's not doing nothing
mata's old matic is old you're not
starting i want my bench to be strong
if anything i'm disrespecting you i'm
saying yeah you can come and eat bench
you're not getting that's what i'm
saying
the only person who i'm taking in the
starting 11 right now
right because sancho's going to be on
the left
right
marcus rashford isn't at it right now so
i put sakura ronaldo up front bruno over
older guard party concu hundred percent
pogba and party yeah varane
i'll take lindelof actually over
gabrielle no you might take gabrielle
over maguire
okay that's what i'm saying about the
bench
this is what i'm talking about okay so
there you go
just know that we had we we did the same
thing
actually after all of this show
you've agreed with me so what is all
this about
i'd just like to give you a bit of you'd
like to light me up because when you do
play us we'll see man for man who's
better
because
has a higher ceiling than jaden sancho
three
two one
i don't
ah
that is a really hard one it's hard and
you know what i feel like i don't watch
rashford enough so i'm gonna be
completely biased here right i'm sorry
yeah yeah um
i just feel like i don't
pay attention to him enough since he's
joined manchester united but obviously
and and because he hasn't played that
much
um and he hasn't produced as much as
everyone expected them to so it's hard
to compare the two where sakura has come
in he's been great i've been a
consistent player and had to be yeah and
he's become a first-team player he's got
the number seven now i mean the really
good thing about bakayosaka is what he
does is that he's very good with the
ball at his feet and driving at people
and off the ball i see a lot more
intensity in his runs when he doesn't
have it to give defenders nightmares
whereas a jaden sancho he just is a
technical player he needs he can do it
in tight spaces he can quickly skip past
someone but that raw acceleration
i don't think i think sakura probably
has that over him you know
confidence as well though 100 you look
in the euros you know sakura was suckers
the star or coming in ahead of jane
sancho but sancho sancho's been around
longer
and has played at a higher level in
terms of you know winning things at
dortmund and the champions he's gone to
barcelona where he scored he's played
against big fireman escort like he's
been there and done it a little bit
longer which is a bit of an unfair stick
to beat sacko with because he's just
young
really my metric is the time but
i have to stick with my guy i just think
he's if i had to choose one ever so
slightly i'd say jaden these are the
ones where you're kind of gonna back
your guy yeah because it will be
interesting to see how much further
sakura can go because
we've seen that he's been you know what
you call a utility place utilizing
different positions started off at left
back and we've seen the talent he had
but he wasn't playing regularly because
he wasn't really meant to be in a squad
under emery and then he started playing
more and more games and now he's become
a forward and you think what else can he
do and how much further can he go under
our other
massive question then
will saka have to leave arsenal to get
the maximum
out of his potential
[Laughter]
so basically arsenal are going to be
able to give him
what are you doing i'm asking you
questions you know because you know why
cause i was having a conversation with
my friends every day and i was just like
i'm so worried because
certain managers got their eyes on
sakura and i'm just like i'm like clock
hands off
because i can see and we can see how
even pep like we can see how certain
players have developed under ceremonies
like sterling under pep
clops we've seen what he's doing with
liverpool in general and i just think
obviously a young player
playing at his best right now he can be
better and he's probably thinking to
himself
i could be winning champion i could be
doing what phil foden's doing i could be
in the champions league i could be doing
this um
like
yeah racing for the premier league title
and obviously it worries me a lot um but
i just hope we can hold him down it
depends on who it depends because we've
seen so many great players come come to
arsenal not reach their full potential
go to other teams and win things and
then other players that stayed and
probably regretted it and think well i
do what he did yeah i'm not trying to do
the batman thing but i kind of um
that is like a track record of arsenal i
know isn't it like really of the best
players going i can't get what i need
here fabregas van persie um henry even
alexander khaled left and went to basa
adebayor
like the list goes on but actually in
the case of sakura as outside of looking
in i don't think you've got anything to
worry about
right in the immediate to i think he
signs a new deal even if you don't get
champions league
because i think he's so young and still
in the early stages you can still get
another two to three years i was
thinking then
if it if he doesn't get anything then
but hopefully i'm wrong actually and he
doesn't leave no united no no no no what
did you do what's he doing there
ain't winning enough in there
nicola tetta would do a better job at
united than ralph ragnick is doing now
why
no no and you know what
it ain't even i don't know how to answer
this it ain't even because
it might annoy me
i'm saying can i stay on the line
i'd rather you didn't please okay
the only reason i'm saying disagree is
because i've i don't know the ins and
outs what happens at arsenal's but i've
come under the illusion that he doesn't
like
big egos we've seen he could never
handle a ronaldo be gone it's not about
handling them i just feel like i just
feel like he doesn't like that character
around we've seen the whole message all
situations like i don't know what
happened to the extent but those were
two big characters flamboyant guys well
not miserable but i mean big characters
um and i feel like with all the
characters at manchester united he will
just overhaul the whole thing and change
it up i agree with you on that and
another reason is that
man united is very chaotic as well at
the moment and i feel like it doesn't he
wouldn't have much control i feel like
no i feel like
arteta is getting the backing and the
understanding from the likes of edu and
whoever else is up there on the board to
work out a plan at man united if arteta
was to go into that i don't think he has
the environment to thrive so i actually
strongly disagree that arteta could do a
better job than ralph rania and actually
we're actually we've actually got better
underground friendly no might not look
like it yeah you laugh you laugh like
you said you don't watch my united for
nine minutes i do no you don't most
times
we just can't score at the moment but
you know we're defending a lot better
concealing their skulls we just can't
score who would your number one choice
be for the next maya united manager i
like
either ten hog
or pochettino there's some outsiders
like louis enrique i think he's
brilliant but um yeah i haven't got a
front front front runner i just wanted
to be the right person i wanted to take
our time with it as awesome
stop it sorry
united will win their next trophy before
arsenal win their next trophy
three down two it's a really good one
united will win their trophy before
arsenal win theirs
it is a really hard question
on the premise that we are still
actually in a competition at the time of
recording
i'm gonna go with us
wait what's the question why are we
going to agree because i agree that matt
and i will win the trophy basically
sooner than them i'd be really biased
today
name of the game economy we're like
we're like even though we got kicked out
by nottingham foreign
i even think man united will win the
premier league sooner than
you will it's going to be a long time
because city and liverpool but we're
both way off it but i think too because
with the state that your club's in now
yeah yeah i think that you would only
only because
and it does come down to money and
resources and the stature of the club we
can still attract top
players and we we've been getting in the
champions league a lot more than you
have recently yeah that might change
this season but i just feel like as an
institute manchester united is still a
bigger pool than arsenal because we're
still a bigger club even though
success-wise of the recent years
it hurts because actually we're closer
than we think yeah i don't know i feel
like we're arsenal are just
on this what's it called the process
that you're trusting and it's slowly
working so
within two years that arteta has been at
arsenal he's already won the fa cup and
he's building something
it's already in motion you've uh man
united are about to you haven't even
started again you haven't even started
yet you still need to get a manager in
that's a proper full-time manager if
they've got a five-year plan
within that five-year plan arsenal
should win something your five-year plan
hasn't started yet
i mean so
i have to say arsenal yeah and that's
logically the way you like put that down
it makes it makes does make sense
whatever it is even if it's one of those
whatever it is yeah
and that's what i mean no but but man
united though because we've got
good individuals
we're capable of a cup run i know we
haven't shown that but we got to the
final thing we've got the final europa
league last year do you know who else
has got good individuals
belgium what do they win
but that's why but then but then they're
still going to be expected to keep
challenging and be up there whereas
arsenal in this case i feel like
their players won't get to their peaks
in time before we get our next batch
that's what happens
next match players next manager just the
next process i think if the if i think
if our next process goes really well
massive
if postertino comes in or if 10 however
it is comes in gets a good solid chance
we win with what we've already got
there's no reason why man united can't
click into gear super saiyan arsenal
yeah because look at you look at the
players we've got now
if you add the right ingredients to it
in the summer which is a proper manager
with a clear vision get rid of some of
the like i'm saying the full-backs not
really happy with maybe an extra
centimeter we need another strike out if
you get these things you gotta do a lot
of things first yeah i i think it can
click quicker than what yours arsenal
are already clicking them
they're already clicking
so i think it will happen a lot sooner
but the thing is there's no expectations
from outsiders and that's what makes it
easier for the players so there's not
that pressure but that's why man united
does have that expectation and you don't
because
we are buying
good players and we will be continue to
be able to get top players on big money
and i think that
is that that actual point that we have
that expectancy and you don't is why i
actually think
we will act on that no no i'm not saying
arsenal because i have the expectancy
i'm saying rival fans don't expect
arsenal to do well but why do you think
that is because if you don't have
superstars in our squad why is that or
is it because arsenal of late has been
eighth and eighth and hasn't been in the
champions league since wenger that's
what i mean you're way behind
you can't trust me i don't know i
genuinely think she stressed me so long
did you hear it
i'm trying to be respectful
yeah
but
in all honesty it's got to change
sometime this is going to be what the
third rebuild for free but i've even
forgotten but
i just feel like
we've got more
tools hopefully we use them right but i
think we'll have more tools to get
the trophy before you do a trophy before
you do nothing
cristiano ronaldo is the greatest player
the premier league has ever seen
are you going to tell me dennis berkamp
no patrick vieira no
tony adams no it's here the honorees
thank you i was waiting for how long are
you going to call it